my name is Antonio Playa I'm an anchor
painter and head of special effects you
waltz legacy is still alive here in
compaint
how do you do what we're sitting in the
original ink and paint room where cells
were painted for these animated films
this is what started Disney Animation
back in the 20s and our department is
keeping that tradition alive what we
create here is what you see on camera to
me it's very important to keep this
legacy alive
well what is the most interesting thing
you're doing in the studio now
well the present time we're making the
future life hard for me the future of
cartoon yes the very emotional life in
seven boroughs
back in those days animation was still
in its infancy they didn't know what
animation was capable of doing while
Disney wanted to be different and do
better than any other studios we have to
realize I actually remove books nobody I
could bring in two teachers we were
self-taught the inky part of Snow White
was unique because it used a lot of
colors on the lines if you compare our
inking to other Studios they only use
one color the process of inking and
painting is we receive the drawing and
production days this would be the actual
animators pencil drawing and then our
job is to transfer those lines onto the
cell and these are my instructions they
tell me what lines to do with what
colors we were glows because we don't
want the cells to get damaged
and also the gloves help us glide our
hand on the cell once we inked all the
lines on top we flipped the cell then we
paint the cell on the back once the cell
is inked and painted then the cell goes
to the multi-plane camera to get shot
and this is what we see in film it takes
24 cells to make a second of the film to
create snow white it took about 200,000
individual cells to create the whole
film
Walt wanted to create art not cartoons
he wanted to touch on people's emotions
with every laughter must be appears you
make people cry you made people ask you
many people walk out of there inspired
if it wasn't for Snow White's hand drawn
hand paint pen painted storytelling that
received an award there wouldn't be that
category for animated films he called it
art so with Snow White he accomplished
that
you